and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review this means of escape
ever seen in my life
these the season to be spoilers Joey
walk into the movie theater and it says
these are Christmas Carol oh I love this
version with Mickey Mouse's ghost McDuck
playing the roles and then suddenly
that's old man pops up with Richard
Nixon's nose and Jay Leno's cheap glass
huge McDuck that's Larry King after
burning in the shower pudding will the
book opens up and it says a Christmas
carol and we see Scrooge watching down
the street and then it says a Christmas
carol again okay what's with all these
movies showing their titles twice first
Terminator Salvation now this do you
think we're gonna forget the title in
five seconds actually give him what I
just smoked this map bad idea so food is
the meanest man in town when suddenly is
visited by a ghost or Jacob Marley it's
fruit is like I see Paranormal Activity
and I can't do anything to me into the
last five minutes
Marley is like don't worry is still to
be haunted by three spirits and the
first one is a candlestick man with his
hand on fire
any set my head on fire once twice me
time flooring the most is less Freddy
any soul food stress health nights he
was in the past
every ghost is like you expected is like
just shift into these hideous disgusting
faces damage and Jim Carrey played this
for the next dose to appear this eat the
doctor Christmas print and he needs the
floor disappear that's what I see when I
look down at the floor 24/7 it'll be
super close to Christmas present is like
your decision do I know all your friends
think you're right
you and I back to this home Tiny Tim
observed so this movie really shows the
true meaning of Christmas and that is to
not be I do in fact just change it Mary
stop being a douche day and we can
change all the Christmas carols have
yourself a merry stop being a douche
game
oh I submit your recording I don't need
the biggest thing since William Hung
okay maybe not that good this is Jerry
Busey
supposed to pee